hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
heute ist sie wieder mit dabei und wir
werden heute einen badischen rahmen
kuchen backen und zwar ist es hier bei
uns in baden ein typischer kuchen den
man dann mit dem zucker bestreut
serviert uns dieser kuchen data süß aber
ist ihnen zum beispiel zu einer deftigen
kartoffelsuppe also ich finde die
kombination wirklich richtig lecker ihr
denkt wahrscheinlich auch gerade
schmeckt ja gar nicht aber es schmeckt
wirklich gut also deftige kartoffelsuppe
und die süße rahmen kuchen mit synthes
ist wirklich die perfekte kombination
aber heute gibt es wie gesagt die vom
süßen kuchen und ich sehe der murat
dubai schon auf die zunge geht will ich
spät ist
nein im schwäbischen die zivis auch mir
hat das gleiche rezept nur es ist halt
schwierig aber wir zwei partner wobei
durch ein fenster in der pfalz geboren
egal du bist auch partnerin wir backen
jetzt diesen rahmen kuchen und zwar ist
unten ein schöner hefeteig drin und dann
kommt eben diese rahmen schicht ist sich
auch im wirklich einfacher kuchen und
man kann ihn sogar nach dem backen
einfrieren und einfach bei bedarf wieder
aufbauen also meistens macht man einfach
auch die doppelte menge bugs zwei kuchen
einer wird eingefangen einer wird direkt
gegessen
eigentlich auch typisch schwäbisch
weiter haben massive ein arbeitsgang
features und hör auf zu sanieren zu
sagen dass die partnerin ist sie spaß
wie die mama
nein du auf dein kind zu wie sie es
lustig übrigens noch mittel die
windpocken abgenommen werden also ich
zeig euch mal kurz die zutaten und zwar
brauchen wir einen halben würfel hefe
ich brauche ein esslöffel wasser als
warmes wasser genau 40 gramm zucker 250
gramm 40 milliliter einen halben
teelöffel und mutter 40 grafiken super
heiß gemacht
jetzt starte ich direkt mit der hefe und
da partie war eingefroren deswegen stets
bisschen feucht das macht jetzt aber gar
nichts und zwar gehen hat jetzt direkt
ins wasser
man kann hilfe einfrieren und dann
einfach bei bedarf auftauen nicht in
heißes wasser sondern einfach nur in
warmes wasser die lh pröll schlug jetzt
verrühren wir das kurz und da jetzt noch
ein bisschen zucker mit dazu ist der
unterschied bei trockenhefe und normaler
hilfe also ich bin immer ganz gerne
frische hefe natürlich kann man auch
trockenhefe nehmen da muss man dann halt
die doppelte menge nehmen also
frischhefe nämlich jetzt einen halben
würfel und bei trockenhefe müsst ihr ein
päckchen benutzen
trockenhefe hat man halt immer auf
vorrat das könnte eigentlich lagern so
lange ihr wollt frischhefe muss
natürlich gleich verbraucht werden oder
ist halt ein deswegen habe ich
eigentlich fast nie trockenhefe das geht
ja das warst du in die rührschüssel ja
noch der zucker mit drei interesse
dann dass wir wieder so eine helferin
hat genau über 40 lässt die macht das
richtig gut kennt auch mit dem finger so
wissen
super und jetzt geben wir noch das mehl
mit rein das ganze und milch gebe ich
jetzt nur mit dazu wenn ich mir ich
brauche weil es auch ziemlich groß das
heißt wenn der teig zu trocken ist noch
mit schreien aber jetzt kommt noch ein
halber teelöffel salz macht es kurz und
fangen jetzt schon mal anzuhören
mit ingres zu kneten und gibt gleich
aber noch die butter mit rein bevor ich
mich dazu geben
der teig ist jetzt fertig daraus wurde
ist auch eine richtig schöne kugel
samira wartet schon auf ihr stück hier
bitteschön und ich musste den teig jetzt
erstmal aufgehen lassen
das mache ich jetzt einfach da drin mit
etwas mehl die ist den teig york macht
das klingt ehrlich einfach ein bisschen
mehr noch trüber und jetzt denke ich
ihnen gleich ab und lassen für etwa eine
halbe stunde auf gehen bis es nicht mehr
doppelt hat und dann können wir gleich
die rahmen schicht machen schmeckt gut
gehen der hefeteig ist gut aufgegangen
und habe hier bereits meine form
gerichtet ihr könnt entweder eine
springform nehmen mit 26 cm durchmesser
oder so wie ich den bug rahmen aber die
müsste dann auf jeden fall mit
backpapier einschlagen den habe ich auch
auf 26 cm eingestellt und jetzt soll ich
den teig etwas größer aus so etwa 3 cm
größer als die form also eigentlich
insgesamt sechs zentimeter größer denn
ich möchte einen drei zentimeter hohen
rand gleich
jetzt sind etwa 32 33 zentimeter große
ausgerollt und jetzt bespricht die
formel festakt renz prey und zwar
deswegen dass der teig es gleich ein
bisschen dran kleben bleibt
so stellt damit nimmt sie immer wieder
runter und dann lege ich jetzt die form
damit aus und vor meinen drei zentimeter
hohen rand
ich habe die frau mit dem teig ausgelegt
jetzt kann ich noch die füllung
vorbereiten und dafür habe ich hier
vorne die zutaten
ich brauche 100 gramm zucker 40 gramm
speisestärke 400 km schlagsahne 400
gramm schmand oder crème fraiche und
hier noch etwas vanille extrakt und das
geht ganz einfach ich früher einfach
alle zu tragen kurz mit dem schneebesen
während amiras und da oben jetzt zuguckt
rühren wir jetzt das alles durch wir
wollen die masse aber jetzt nicht
luftdicht schlagen deswegen wirklich nur
bei niedriger stufe ganz kurz verrühren
bis sich alles gut verbunden hat und ich
habe stets war vergessen mir
hinzustellen es kommen noch zwei eier
mit in den teig mit dem die füllung
machst du das 2 1 nur kurz einrühren
aber jetzt fühle ich die masse in den
vorbereiteten teig und zum glück ist nur
noch eingefallen mit dabei denn sonst
etwa gleich keine rahmen kuchen sondern
flüssigen guss und den ofen habe ich
jetzt bereits vorgeheizt auf 175 180
grad ober unterhitze und da wird der
teig jetzt für etwa 40 bis 45 minuten
gebacken
aber ich schau 24 nach 40 minuten 1
mein badische rahmen kuchen ist fertig
ich habe eine halbe stunde einen
kühlschrank stenose und jetzt nämlich
dem tor weiter uns neben den kuchen
herunter und setzte ihn auf den
kartenständer das ist ausgelegt
es hat sich schon hassan das tier wird
war dich halt jetzt kommt ihr noch etwas
zimt zucker drüber also hatte den
kühlschrank für auch vielleicht gerade
untertitel mache ich hatte den kuchen
etwa eine halbe stunde im kühlschrank
also nachdem er abgekühlt war auf
zimmertemperatur noch meinen kühlschrank
dann kann man ihn nämlich besser
abschneiden was ich zum zurückzieht
sogar ist genau das ist einfach sind und
etwas zucker habe ich immer in so einer
kleinen dose cesana einfach etwas zimt
und etwas zucker und das streich ist auf
den kuchen drauf es gibt ja auch hier
bei uns bei den bäckereien immer diese
ramschladen also die iran bot das ist
genauso hefeteig mit rahmen drauf okay
das reicht so weit ich mag sind ja es
reicht
schneide ich dir ein stück heraus und du
darfst kreis probieren ein lecker sie da
auch aus der kuh
in den kurven gefragt gefällt mir alles
bis auf der name
durch diese schönheit das ist
wunderschön aber was ist jetzt der
unterschied zwischen einem also für mich
sieht es jetzt aus wegen käsekuchen
aber er sagt kein keil käsemasse drin es
ist ja kein quark dann ist es warm im
raum kuchen saurer sahne käse kuchen
schmeckt ihr etwas säuerlicher also da
hätte diesen quark geschmack und das ist
halt jetzt ein rad kuchen und kannst du
dir jetzt die kombination forsche mit
kartoffelsuppe absolut wirklich super
lecker williams verlinkt am ende des
videos meine kartoffelsuppe und dazu uns
seit diesem rahmen
ich kann die kommune zur rutsche das
kann man sich auch nicht vorstellen das
ist wirklich probieren
ich warte aber nämlich bei bei unseren
freunden das recht vor langer zeit habe
ich bei dem fenster geputzt und so
weiter jeden freitag und dann haben das
so gemacht zusammen kartoffel super
gemacht den rahm kuchen hat sie schon
vorbereitet und dann haben wir das
zusammen gegessen
für mich geht es gar nicht der kuchen
ist genial
ich würde den zucker ich habe
erstklassig zu viel zucker essen aber
das ist auch wieder so leicht ein
quatsch also wenig cool also top-act ob
kuchen auch von kubanischer coach gern
danke und ihr seid auch in der nächsten
runde ihr könnt diesen kuchen gerne
nachmachen auch cds - bug.de steht das
genaue rezept und ja ich freue mich wenn
ihr das nach macht und euren badischen
kuchen mit mir teilt auf facebook oder
auf instagram also ich freue mich aufs
nächste mal viel spaß beim nachbacken
und bis bald
so mancher schwäbische nein das
schwäbisch muss raus man kann viel für
uns sich mit dem schwäbisch double nicht
geben